This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 1968, the police department in Menlo Park, California hired a new police chief. His name was Victor Sazankas. And Chief Sazankas' main goal was to reform the police department's image, which wasn't great at the time. That's our own Delaney Hall. Because this was the 1960s, and even in Menlo Park, a small city with manicured lawns and wide suburban streets, it had been a turbulent decade. There were big student-led anti-war demonstrations at Stanford University, which he was right
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。1968年，加利福尼亚州门洛帕克的警察局聘请了一位新警察局长。他的名字叫维克托·萨赞卡斯。萨赞卡斯局长的主要目标是重塑警察局的形象，当时这个形象可不太好。那是我们自己的德兰妮·霍尔。因为那是20世纪60年代，即使在门洛帕克这样一个修剪整齐的草坪和宽阔的郊区街道的小城市里，那也是一个动荡的十年。斯坦福大学发生了由学生主导的大规模反战游行，而斯坦福就在他
nearby. Joan Bias, the folk singer, created a commune called Struggle Mountain in the foothills above the city, and leaders in the African-American community were organizing protests to demand better treatment and services. The Menlo Park Police had clashed with these protesters, sometimes violently. And after years and years of this, the department had a pretty rough reputation. Had a reputation for being a very tough police department,
附近。民谣歌手琼·贝兹在城市上方的山麓建立了一个名为“奋斗山”的公社，非裔美国人社区的领导人正在组织抗议活动，要求得到更好的对待和更好的服务。门洛帕克警方曾与这些抗议者发生冲突，有时甚至是暴力的冲突。经过年复一年的这种对抗，该部门的名声相当糟糕。它有着一个非常强硬的警察局的名誉，
a very aggressive police department, and somewhat of a very anti-race kind of a police department. That's Dominic Paloso. He was hired in 1970 by Chief Susencus, the guy who wanted to change this culture. He's one of these type of guys that would come into a room and would just fill in the room. You know, and everybody kind of sits back and says,
一个非常激进的警察局，在某种程度上甚至有点排斥其他种族的警察局。那是多米尼克·帕洛索。他在1970年被萨赞卡斯局长雇佣，也就是那个想要改变这种文化的人。他是那种走进一个房间就能充满整个房间气场的人。你知道的，每个人都会靠回椅背上说，
I think we better listen and go along with this guy. Chief Susencus had hired Dominic right out of the Jesuit seminary where Dominic had been studying to be a priest. Susencus liked hiring officers from non-traditional law enforcement backgrounds and with higher levels of education. It was just one of his strategies for reforming the department. He also let his officers grow their hair out and have beards and mustaches. He changed all the pseudo-military titles
我想我们最好还是听从并顺从这个人吧。萨赞卡斯局长直接从耶稣会神学院招募了多米尼克，当时多米尼克正在那里学习成为一名神父。萨赞卡斯喜欢从非传统执法背景且受过高等教育的人中招募警官。这只是他改革警局的策略之一。他还允许他的警官留长发、留胡子和八字胡。他把所有的准军事头衔
to more corporate ones. Sargents became managers, for example, and lieutenants became directors. Officers in the department had mixed feelings about all these changes, but one was more controversial than the others. For a long time, officers in Menlo Park had worn a variation of the traditional dark blue police uniform.
改成了更具企业风格的头衔。例如，警长变成了经理，中尉变成了总监。局里的警官对所有这些变化有着复杂的感受，但其中一项比其他任何一项都更具争议。长期以来，门洛帕克的警官一直穿着传统深蓝色警服的变体。
But Chief Susencus thought that style was too intimidating and aggressive. So the chief came up with something totally different. It was really nice, kind of a dark green blazer with some black thread in it. and aggressive. So the chief came up with something totally different. It was really nice, kind of a dark green blazer with some black thread in it. We wore pastel colored solid shirts with a tie and slacks. Instead of a metal badge, the blazer sported an embroidered patch that sort of looked like a coat of arms. Guns and handcuffs remained hidden under the jacket. All in all the officers look kind of like grown-up prep school students, but with guns. They even had pocket protectors
但萨赞卡斯局长认为这种风格太具有恐吓性和侵略性了。于是局长想出了一个完全不同的方案。这真的很棒，有点像深绿色西装外套，里面夹杂着一些黑色线。并且具有侵略性。所以局长想出了一个完全不同的方案。这真的很棒，有点像深绿色西装外套，里面夹杂着一些黑色线。我们穿着粉彩色纯色衬衫，系着领带，穿着休闲裤。西装外套上没有金属徽章，而是有一个刺绣徽章，看起来有点像家族徽章。枪支和手铐仍然藏在夹克底下。总而言之，警官们看起来有点像长大了的预科学校学生，但带着枪。他们甚至还有口袋保护套
with the Menlo Park Police logo on it that would slide into the pocket of their dress shirts. It seems like the total effect is he was trying to demilitarize the look and attitude of the department. Yeah, I think that would be a correct statement. A lot of the guys we join in police departments are from the military. And because of the nature of the work, it can't be very militaristic, shall we say,
上面印有门洛帕克警察局的标志，可以滑入他们正装衬衫的口袋里。看起来整体效果是，他试图将警察部门的外观和态度去军事化。是的，我认为这是一个正确的说法。我们加入警察部门的很多伙计都来自军队。由于工作性质，它不能是非常军事化的，我们可以这么说，
an organization and training and all those kinds of things. And he was trying to calm it down. But Chief Susancus was also messing with a tradition that would prove extremely hard to change. Because the blue military style uniform had a history that went back more than 100 years. What we've asked police officers to wear over the years says a lot about what we've expected of them and how we feel about them. It even says a lot about how they feel about themselves. Back in America's colonial days, law enforcement looked really different than it does now.
组织、训练以及所有这些事情。他正试图让它平静下来。但萨赞卡斯局长也触动了一个事实证明极其难以改变的传统。因为蓝色军装风格的历史可以追溯到100多年前。多年来我们要求警察穿的衣服，很大程度上说明了我们对他们的期望以及我们对他们的看法。它甚至很大程度上说明了他们对自己的看法。回到美国的殖民地时期，执法工作看起来与现在非常不同。
In New England, there were these informal groups, generally known as the watch, that patrolled neighborhoods looking for crime. No uniforms, no sort of organizational policies that they had to follow is basically every able man. Chad Posec teaches in the Department of Criminal Justice and Criminology at Georgia Southern University. If they saw somebody that needed help, a fire, crime on the corner, it would just be an informal group that would sort of respond to that.
在新英格兰，有这些非正式的群体，通常被称为守夜人，他们在社区里巡逻寻找犯罪分子。没有制服，也没有他们必须遵守的某种组织政策，基本上是每个有能力的男子。查德·波西克在佐治亚南方大学刑事司法与犯罪学系任教。如果他们看到有人需要帮助，比如火灾、街角的犯罪，这就只是一个非正式的群体，会做出某种回应。
So that was in the North. In Southern communities leading up to the Civil War, there were roving patrols that were responsible for suppressing slave revolts and tracking down runaway slaves. They worked for large plantation owners. So very much in the south, early policing was tied to slavery. We're in the north that was more of policing crime
所以那是北方。在内战前的南方社区，有四处巡逻的巡逻队，负责镇压奴隶起义和搜寻逃跑的奴隶。他们为大型种植园主工作。所以在南方，早期的警务工作在很大程度上与奴隶制息息相关。而在北方，则更多是关于打击犯罪
in these large urban areas. These unofficial patrols were how early law enforcement worked for decades. It wasn't until the 1820s that modern policing began to take shape. Thanks to a British statesman named Sir Robert Pio. Before Pio came along, policing in London looked a lot like it did in colonial America. Informal and loosely organized.
在这些大型城市地区。这些非官方的巡逻队就是早期执法运作了几十年的方式。直到19世纪20年代，现代警务工作才开始成形。这要归功于一位名叫罗伯特·皮尔爵士的英国政治家。在皮尔出现之前，伦敦的警务工作看起来很像殖民地时期的美国。非正式且组织松散。
And Pio recognized that there were problems with this model. People not taking it seriously, being drunk on the job, not showing up, falling asleep, and so he wanted to do is create a police department that was based on certain principles. In after years of pushing for reform, Peele succeeded. In 1829, he helped found the London Metropolitan Police, the first modern, full-time city-wide police department. British officers are still known as Bobby's, in honor of Robert Bobby Peele. In Ireland, they called them Pealers with a little less affection. Peele required his officers to wear uniforms that would distinguish them from citizens they were
皮尔认识到这种模式存在问题。人们不把它当回事，在工作时喝酒，缺勤，睡着了，所以他想做的是创建一个基于某些原则的警察局。在多年推动改革之后，皮尔成功了。1829年，他协助创立了伦敦警察厅，这是第一个现代的全职、全市范围的警察局。为了纪念罗伯特·“鲍比”·皮尔，英国警察至今仍被称为“鲍比”（Bobby's）。在爱尔兰，人们称他们为“皮勒斯”（Pealers），带有一点点没那么亲切的意味。皮尔要求他的警官穿着制服，以便将他们与他们
meant to serve, but Peele was also sensitive to how British people might perceive this new police force. Yes, that was a huge concern. Because for so many years, the people were ruled by the military in a military state. Peele wanted the new police uniforms to stand apart from the red coats of the British military. That sort of where we forget our first blue uniform that was a very professional looking. And it was actually stood and stark contrast to the red that you saw with the military. Gradually, Peale's ideas and his blue uniform made their way to the United States. By the early 1900s, police departments across the country
旨在服务的公民区分开来，但皮尔对英国人可能如何看待这支新警察部队也很敏感。是的，这是一个巨大的担忧。因为多年来，人民一直被军队在军事化国家中统治。皮尔希望新的警察制服能够与英国军队的红军装区别开来。这也就是为什么我们忘记了我们的第一套蓝色制服，它看起来非常专业。它实际上与你在军队中看到的红色形成了鲜明的对比。渐渐地，皮尔的想法和他的蓝色制服传到了美国。到20世纪初，全国各地的警察局
had adopted aspects of the style and approach pioneered by the London Metropolitan Police. This included a quasi-military structure and the goal of crime prevention. But there were still some problems. Most early police departments in the US allied themselves with the rich and the powerful like local politicians and business leaders. And you might be thinking, it's still like that now.
都采用了伦敦警察厅首创的风格和方法中的某些方面。这包括准军事结构和预防犯罪的目标。但仍然存在一些问题。美国大多数早期的警察部门都与富人和有权势的人结盟，比如当地的政治家和商业领袖。你可能会想，现在不还是这样吗。
And you might be right, but it was worse than. Like a new mayor would get elected and then would appoint a hand-picked police chief. Then the police chief would hire their family, their friends to become the officers of that department. So very political and obviously if you're the police chief and you sort of work for the mayor of the local politician you're going to
你是对的，但那时候更糟。比如新市长当选，然后会任命一个亲手挑选的警察局长。然后警察局长会雇用他们的家人、朋友来成为该部门的警官。所以非常政治化，显然如果你是警察局长，你某种程度上为市长或当地政治家工作，你就会
serve their purposes first and the community maybe secondarily. It was a patronage system and in most departments recruits didn't receive any special training. They were just handed a badge and a night stick and sent out on patrol. Despite the spiffy new uniforms and their newly organized approach, public trust in the police was dismal. So a reform movement begins to grow across America, and then in 1929 President Herbert Hoover convenes a group called the Wicker-Sham Commission to conduct the first national study of the American criminal justice system.
首先服务于他们的目的，而社区可能退居其次。这是一个恩庇侍从体制，在大多数部门中，新警官没有接受任何专门的训练。他们只是被发给一个徽章和一根警棍，然后就被派去巡逻了。尽管有崭新漂亮的制服和新组织的运作方式，公众对警察的信任度依然极其糟糕。因此，一场改革运动开始在美国各地兴起，然后在1929年，赫伯特·胡佛总统召集了一个名为“ Wickersham委员会”（Wickersham Commission）的小组，对美国刑事司法系统进行了首次全国性研究。
They look at the system from top to bottom. And they basically saw the infiltration of politics into policing as a huge problem. And they said that we need to change up how we do things. The Wicker-Sham report shocked the country by exposing widespread police abuse. It described police routinely beating suspects and holding them illegally for lengthy questioning. And you might be thinking, it's still like that now, and you might be right. But it was worse than. The report included some pretty disturbing accounts, like a suspect who was held by the
他们从上到下审视了这个系统。他们基本上将政治对警务的渗透视为一个巨大的问题。他们说我们需要改变我们做事的方式。威克斯汉姆报告通过揭露普遍存在的警察虐待行为震惊了全国。它描述了警察经常殴打嫌疑人并将其非法拘留以进行长时间审讯。你可能会想，现在不还是这样吗，你是对的。但这比以前更糟。该报告包括一些相当令人不安的记述，比如一名嫌疑人被
ankles from a third story window, and another who was forced to stand in the morgue with his hands on the body of a murder victim. This report, the Wickersham report, really was sort of this turning point and we need to do something different in policing and I think that's what led into this professional era. This new professional era, which continued up until the 1960s and 70s, was characterized by an emphasis on policing as a skilled profession. This old educational film called Your Police lays it out.
脚踝朝下吊在三楼窗户上，还有另一个人被迫站在太平间里，双手按在一个谋杀案受害者的尸体上。这份报告，即威克斯汉姆报告，确实是一个转折点，让我们觉得必须在警务工作上做出改变，我认为这引领了职业化时代。这个新的职业化时代一直持续到20世纪60年代和70年代，其特点是强调警务是一项熟练的专业。这部名为《你的警察》的老教育片对此进行了阐述。
Police departments use modern science to protect you, such as teletype, photography, two-way radio, expert firearms training as standardized by the FBI National Academy. Accident prevention installations and other... Now police were trained to use modern tools and technology, and one of the leading voices for this new method was a guy named August Wolmer. He'd been the first police chief of Berkeley, California, and he helped to write the Wickersham report. Woolmer got his officers to use motorcycles and patrol cars instead of just walking around.
警察部门利用现代科学来保护你，例如电传打字机、摄影、双向无线电、经FBI国家学院标准化的专家枪支训练。事故预防设施和其他……现在警察接受了使用现代工具和技术的培训，这一新方法的主要倡导者之一是一个名叫奥古斯特·沃尔默（August Wolmer）的人。他是加利福尼亚州伯克利的第一任警察局长，并协助撰写了威克斯汉姆报告。沃尔默让他的警官使用摩托车和巡逻车，而不仅仅是四处步行。
That way they could cover bigger areas more efficiently. He was also one of the first chiefs in the US to insist his department used fingerprinting and blood and fiber analysis to help solve crimes. And under his influence, California became a hotbed of police reform from the 1920s through the 1960s, leading, of course, to stuff like chiefs, Hizankus' Blazer uniform experiment in Menlo Park. For a few years, it seemed like chiefs, Hizencus' reforms might be working. In Blazers and ties and pocket protectors, the Menlo Park police definitely looked less
这样他们就能更有效率地覆盖更大的区域。他也是美国最早坚持其部门使用指纹、血液和纤维分析来协助破案的局长之一。在他的影响下，加利福尼亚州从20世纪20年代到60年代成为了警察改革的温床，当然，这也促成了门洛帕克萨赞卡斯局长的西装外套制服实验之类的事情。有几年，萨赞卡斯局长的改革似乎起作用了。穿着西装外套、系着领带并带有口袋保护套，门洛帕克警察看起来确实不那么
intimidating. Here's Dominic Poloso again. He eventually became assistant chief under Susencus. It wasn't like we slacked off and became like oh mercy and forgiveness and love and peace and all that kind of stuff. You know, oh no, but the way we did it and the style that we gave to people, I think, made them feel a lot better about us. And he built up a lot of really good rapport with the community. There was even an early study suggesting that altercations between citizens and the police had declined because of the blazers.
具有威慑力了。这里再次请出多米尼克·帕洛索。他最终成为了萨赞卡斯手下的助理局长。这并不是说我们偷懒变得像哦，仁慈、宽恕、爱、和平以及所有那些乱七八糟的事情一样。你知道的，哦不，但我们做事的方式以及我们带给人们的风格，我认为，让他们对我们的感觉好多了。他与社区建立了非常良好的关系。甚至有一项早期研究表明，因为西装外套，市民与警察之间的冲突减少了。
The study was later challenged, but when it first came out, word began to spread and a few other departments across the country adopted the blazer style. But the uniform experiment also drew a line within the department. On one side, there were the guys like Dominic, who liked what the blazer stood for. They embraced that Chief Susenka's wanted the department to have a calmer, more professional image. There's a lot of guys who want to do this job, but don't want to go out there and knock heads or shoot people or you know whatever like that. They just want to do the best for the community. And I think with our uniform, people who are applying got more the sense that we really
这项研究后来受到了质疑，但当它刚问世时，消息开始传播，全国其他几个部门也采用了西装外套的风格。但制服实验也在部门内部划出了一条线。一方面，有像多米尼克这样的人，他们喜欢西装外套所代表的东西。他们赞同萨赞卡斯局长希望警察局拥有一个更平静、更专业的形象的想法。有很多小伙子想做这份工作，但不想出去跟人拼命或者开枪或者你知道类似的事情。他们只想为社区做最好的事情。我认为我们的制服让应聘者更能感受到我们确实是
work community-minded helping people. On the other side were the old school police officers who missed the traditional uniform and all that it represented. They enjoyed the ego stuff that goes with it. They also enjoy that sense of authority that you show, the clearness of who they are. With the blazer, it just wasn't always that clear. You know, I'd stop a person, I'd say, for violation. And I'd walk up and say, can I see your license? You know, when they look at you, they say, well, let's see your license.
社区导向的、乐于助人的人。另一方面是老派警官，他们怀念传统的制服以及它所代表的一切。他们享受随之而来的自我膨胀。他们还享受那种你所表现出的权威感、他们身份的明晰性。有了西装外套，这种明晰性并不总是存在。你知道的，我会拦住一个人，我会说，因为违章。然后我会走过去说，我能看看你的驾驶证吗？你知道，当他们看着你时，他们会说，好吧，让我看看你的驾驶证。
You know, who are you? Then you point to the little patch and say, well, I'm the police, you know. This is retired sergeant Van Trask. He worked under Sazankas and generally he liked the chief's style and approach, but he admits that it caused some complications. You didn't have that much recognition as a cop, so you kind of... There's a tendency to get more, who are you? You know, I'm the police, you know, I'm sure you are.
你知道，你是谁？然后你指着那个小徽章说，嗯，我是警察，你知道的。这是退休警长范·特拉斯克。他在萨赞卡斯手下工作，总的来说他喜欢局长的风格和方法，但他承认这带来了一些复杂情况。你作为警察的辨识度没那么高，所以你有点……往往会有更多“你是谁？”的情况。你知道的，我是警察，你知道的，我确信你是。
Many officers got so frustrated that they quit. The numbers we've heard on this vary. Van said about half the department left. Dominic thinks it was even higher. I would guess that in his first four years as police chief, we had about a 75% turnover. People just left and went to other departments. But I think they just couldn't take his overall thinking, out of the box thinking, his philosophy and stuff,
许多警官非常沮丧以至于辞职了。我们听到的关于这个数字的说法不尽相同。范说大约有一半的部门人员离开了。多米尼克认为比例甚至更高。我猜在他担任警察局长的头四年里，我们的员工流失率大约在75%左右。人们纷纷离开并去了其他部门。但我认为他们只是无法接受他的整体思维、打破常规的思维、他的哲学之类的事，
so they all just abandoned. And eventually, Siz the box thinking, his philosophy and stuff, so they all just abandon. And eventually, Sizankus left, too, to take over as the chief of a police department in Stamford, Connecticut. You know, there's some talk that he was actually kind of encouraged to leave. And not long after he left, the department switched back to the traditional uniform style. Sizankus passed away in 1980. The year that Cezanquez joined the Menlo Park Police Department, 1968, represented an important turning point for law enforcement in the U.S.
所以他们都放弃了。最终，萨赞卡斯也离开了，去接管康涅狄格州斯坦福的一个警察局。你知道，有一些传言说他其实是有点被鼓励离开的。在他离开后不久，该部门又改回了传统的制服风格。萨赞卡斯于1980年去世。萨赞卡斯加入门洛帕克警察局的年份——1968年，代表了美国执法部门的一个重要转折点。
The community policing approach championed by Cezanquez would continue to gain traction through the 80s and 90s, as departments across the country tried to build better, less combative relationships with their local communities. But there had always been attention between the more community oriented side of policing and the more military side, and that was about to intensify.
萨赞卡斯所倡导的社区警务方法在80和90年代继续获得支持，因为全国各地的部门都试图与当地社区建立更好、冲突更少的联系。但偏向社区一面的警务与偏向军事一面的警务之间一直存在着张力，而这种张力即将加剧。
In recent years, crime in this country has grown nine times as fast as population. At the current rate, the crimes of violence in America will double by 1972. We cannot accept that kind of future for America. In 1968, Richard Nixon ran for president on a promise of law and order. He tapped into all the paranoia and unease that had grown during the turmoil of the 1960s. His campaign ads were full of these scary images of urban unrest and rioting, and they ended with his slogan written across the screen. Vote like your whole world
近年来，这个国家的犯罪率增长速度是人口增长速度的九倍。按照目前的增速，到1972年，美国的暴力犯罪将翻一番。我们不能接受美国出现那种未来。1968年，理查德·尼克松竞选总统时许下了法律与秩序的承诺。他利用了在20世纪60年代的动荡中滋生的所有偏和不安。他的竞选广告充斥着这些城市动乱和暴乱的可怕画面，最后以他的标语横跨屏幕结束。投票就像你的整个世界
depended on it. I pledge to you, the wave of crime is not going to be the wave of the future in America. Shortly after taking office, Nixon vowed to fight the war on crime, which had been started by his predecessor, Lyndon Johnson. He also declared a war on drugs. Again, criminal justice professor, Chad Posick. One I think the language is very important, right? You don't have, say, drug prevention or a crime prevention.
取决于它一样。我向你们保证，犯罪浪潮不会成为美国未来的浪潮。上任后不久，尼克松发誓要打击由他的前任林登·约翰逊发起的打击犯罪战争。他还宣布了一场毒品战争。再次请出刑事司法教授查德·波西克。首先我认为语言非常重要，对吧？你没有说什么预防毒品或预防犯罪。
It's the war, war on drugs, the war on crime. So you do see an escalation during this time on how crime is responded to, and it's responded to, like they're responding to war. War of course requires specialized equipment, And around this same time, the government established the law enforcement assistance administration, a now-defunct federal agency that gave lots of money to local police departments so they could buy new fangled crime fighting tools. You see this uptick and support for all sorts of policing, but especially riot gear and SWAT teams and armored vehicles and weapons and bulletproof fast and those types of things.
这是战争，对毒品的战争，对犯罪的战争。所以在这个时期，你确实看到了应对犯罪的方式在升级，它的应对方式就像是在应对战争一样。战争当然需要专门的设备，大约在同一时期，政府成立了执法援助局（Law Enforcement Assistance Administration），这是一个现已不复存在的联邦机构，向地方警察部门提供大量资金，以便他们购买新奇的打击犯罪工具。你看到了对各种警务支持的上升，尤其是防暴装备、特警队、装甲车、武器和防弹背心以及诸如此类的东西。
Even small rural departments were getting their hands on stuff like helicopters and serious crowd control gear like shields and helmets. And new paramilitary divisions of the police, like SWAT teams, began using this gear. Some exchanged the traditional blue uniform for camouflage outfits, known as the Battle Dress Uniform. They began to look more military. As this kind of equipment and style spread, so did more militarized policing tactics. Conducting raids, crackdowns, and harshly enforcing laws,
甚至连小型农村部门也开始获得直升机和严厉的控场装备，如盾牌和头盔。警察的新准军事部门，如特警队，开始使用这些装备。一些人将传统的蓝色制服换成了被称为作战服（Battle Dress Uniform）的迷彩服。他们开始看起来更像军人。随着这种设备和风格的传播，更加军事化的警务战术也随之蔓延。进行突袭、打击和严厉执行法律，
and they're behind the mask that they wear in riot gear, or the big, huge vests that they wear in the SWAT team. This trend continued to the 80s and 90s in lots of police departments across the country. It accelerated in many places after 9-11, as police departments became closer with federal law enforcement agencies and started thinking of themselves as part of the first line of defense in a new war, the war on terror. New federal programs emerged
他们藏在防暴装备的面具后面，或者穿着特警队的巨大背心后面。这一趋势在80年代和90年代延续到全国各地的许多警察部门。9·11事件后，许多地方的这一趋势加速了，因为警察部门与联邦执法机构的关系更加密切，开始认为自己是新战争——反恐战争——第一道防线的一部分。新的联邦计划涌现出来
that sent surplus military equipment from Iraq and Afghanistan to local police departments across the country. Which brings us to today. The police just arrested someone. They're basically confronting the police. They all get them over this arrest. Back off, please. Across the country there have been highly publicized protests against police shootings of unarmed black men, women and even children. And these protests have sparked bigger conversations about police violence and also how our police
将来自伊拉克和阿富汗的过剩军事装备运送给全国各地的地方警察部门。这就把我们带到了今天。警察刚抓了一个人。他们基本上在与警察对抗。他们全都冲过来阻止这次逮捕。请退后。在全国各地，针对警察枪击未武装的黑人男性、女性甚至儿童的抗议活动广受关注。这些抗议活动引发了关于警察暴力以及我们的警察
look. For several nights this week, this was Ferguson, Missouri. Tanks, combat gear, assault rifles. It looked like a military operation. The current mistrust of police seems to mirror what was going on in Menlo Park back in 1968, pre-blazer, but on a more dramatic scale. Back in the 1960s, it was big conversations about the role of police and the community that led Chief Sizankas to make changes to the Menlo Park Unals. The current mistrust of police seems to mirror what was going on in Menlo Park back in 1968, pre-blazer, but on a more dramatic scale. Back in the 1960s, it was big conversations about the role of police and the community that led Chief Sizankas to make changes to the Menlo Park Unals. Back in the 1960s, it was big conversations about the role of police and the community
外表的大规模讨论。本周有几个晚上，这里是密苏里州的弗格森。坦克、作战装备、突击步枪。这看起来像是一场军事行动。目前对警察的不信任似乎反映了1968年门洛帕克穿西装外套前发生的事情，但规模更为戏剧化。早在20世纪60年代，正是关于警察在社区中的角色的巨大讨论，促使萨赞卡斯局长对门洛帕克制服做出了改变。目前对警察的不信任似乎反映了1968年门洛帕克穿西装外套前发生的事情，但规模更为戏剧化。早在20世纪60年代，正是关于警察在社区中的角色的巨大讨论，促使萨赞卡斯局长对门洛帕克制服做出了改变。早在20世纪60年代，正是关于警察在社区中的角色的大规模讨论
that led Chief Sizankas to make changes to the Menlo Park uniform. Today, at least so far, no departments have taken steps that drastic, but in Minneapolis, they're taking a small step in that general direction. Manyapolis SWAT teams will soon unveil a new look to make them a peer less intimidating. In February of 2016, the Minneapolis Police Department changed the color of their SWAT uniforms, from a military green to a more traditional navy blue. This happened about four months after the city saw widespread protests. After the police shot and killed an unarmed black man named Jamar Clark.
促使萨赞卡斯局长改变了门洛帕克的制服。今天，至少目前为止，还没有哪个部门采取如此激烈的步骤，但在明尼阿波利斯，他们正朝着那个大致方向迈出一小步。明尼阿波利斯特警队很快将推出新外观，使其看起来不那么令人生畏。2016年2月，明尼阿波利斯警察局将他们的特警制服颜色从军绿色改为更传统的藏青色。这发生在全市范围内爆发广泛抗议活动大约四个月后。在此之前，警察开枪打死了一名名叫贾马尔·克拉克的未武装黑人男子。
The Minneapolis Police Department declined to talk with us about the uniform change, but they made it clear in other interviews that this color change is about public perception and rebranding. We are police, we are not military, we don't train with the military, we're not associated with the military, we're the Minneapolis Police Department, and we want to be reflective of our own community, and our own image. What's not totally clear is if the color of the uniform actually matters. I mean, they can wear pink, but if they're coating guns
明尼阿波利斯警察局拒绝与我们谈论制服颜色的改变，但他们在其他采访中明确表示，这种颜色的改变是为了公众的看法和品牌重塑。我们是警察，我们不是军队，我们不与军队一起训练，我们与军队没有关联，我们是明尼阿波利斯警察局，我们希望反映我们自己的社区和我们自己的形象。完全不清楚的是制服的颜色是否真的重要。我的意思是，他们可以穿粉红色，但如果他们配备了枪支
and rubber bullets and mace and tasers and everything else. This is Candice Montgomery. She's an activist with Black Lives Matter, and she's taken part in protests in Minneapolis against the police. A color's not gonna change that dynamic, an entire overhaul of the policing system, it's gonna change that dynamic and people's responses.
和橡皮子弹、催泪瓦斯、电击枪以及其他一切。这是坎迪斯·蒙哥马利。她是“黑人的命也是命”运动的活动人士，她曾参加明尼阿波利斯抗议警察的活动。颜色不会改变这种动态，整个警察系统的彻底改革才会改变这种动态以及人们的反应。
Of course, the problems police are facing today can't be solved by uniform change alone, but a changing uniform can be an important symbol, a way for police departments to signal to their communities that they want to have a better relationship. In the case of Chief Susancus in Menlo Park, the uniform experiment did help lead to bigger changes. Requiring officers to wear blazers meant a certain kind of officer was drawn to the police department, the kind who was willing to get on board with the more significant reforms
当然，警察今天面临的问题不能仅仅通过更换制服来解决，但更换制服可以成为一个重要的象征，是警察部门向其社区发出信号的一种方式，表明他们希望建立更好的关系。就门洛帕克的萨赞卡斯局长而言，制服实验确实有助于带来更大的改变。要求警官穿西装外套吸引了某种特定类型的警官加入警察部门，这种人愿意支持萨赞卡斯想要做出的更重要的改革。
that Zizenka's wanted to make. And even though the department eventually abandoned the blazers, many of the other changes stuck. Here's former Menlo Park assistant chief Dominic Paloso again. Here's former Menlo Park assistant chief Dominic Paloso again. Vic was definitely ahead of his time. And, you know, as with most people who are ahead of their time, you don't have a crowd of people that all kind of stand up and cheer for you. But it would be very interesting because within, I'd say, 10 or 15 years, almost every police department in our area. Even though they didn't change the uniform or the titles of the organizational chart,
尽管该部门最终放弃了西装外套，但许多其他改变保留了下来。这里再次请出前门洛帕克助理局长多米尼克·帕洛索。这里再次请出前门洛帕克助理局长多米尼克·帕洛索。维克绝对走在了他的时代前面。而且，你知道的，正如大多数走在时代前面的人一样，你不会有一大群人全都站起来为你欢呼。但这将会非常有趣，因为我想在10到15年内，我们地区的几乎每个警察局。尽管他们没有改变制服或组织架构图的头衔，
we're taking on that real big kind of community policing thing. They went ahead and did it because that was the signs of the times. 99% invisible was produced this week byaney Hall, with Katie Mingle, Sam Greenspan, Sri Fusev, Kurt Colstead, Avery Trouffleman, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks this week to Darryl Lindsay of the Menlo Park Police Department, Richard Johnson, Robert Mauro, David Cooper, and Tom DuPont. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arxon, an architecture and interiors firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California.
都在采用那种非常宏大的社区警务模式。他们继续这样做了，因为那是时代的选择。“99%隐形”本周由德兰妮·霍尔制作，参与制作的有凯蒂·明格尔、萨姆·格林斯潘、斯里·福泽夫、库尔特·科尔施泰德、埃弗里·特鲁夫曼以及我罗曼·马尔斯。本周特别感谢门洛帕克警察局的达里尔·林赛、理查德·约翰逊、罗伯特·毛罗、大卫·库珀和汤姆·杜邦。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW电台的项目，在位于加利福尼亚州美丽奥克兰市中心的一家建筑与室内设计公司Arxon的办公室制作。
You can find the show and like the show on Facebook, you can follow us all on Twitter and Instagram for the best way to explore the 99% invisible activity that shapes the design of our world and to click around the hundreds and hundreds of stories on 99p i dot org Radio Topeia from PRX you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞该节目，你可以在Twitter和Instagram上关注我们，这是探索塑造我们世界设计的99%隐形活动的最佳方式，也可以点击99pi.org上的成百上千个故事。来自PRX的Radiootopia。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。